jennifer oz dupuis a quitté l'ontario
pour les laurentides
l'an dernier québec une réputation pour
les problèmes sociaux
donc j'étais très excité d'avoir une
garderie subventionnée d'avoir des
places en garderie puis là je me suis
aperçu très vite que c'était paul k
jennifer voulait recommencer à
travailler en avril huit mois plus tard
faute de places en garderie elle
s'occupe toujours de son fils à temps
plein frustration c'est une diversion
que je vis je viens en bois dormant que
ce tellement épuisée à cinq jours parce
que ça prend beaucoup d'énergie
stéphanie bernier se heurtent au même
problème
elle et sa famille ont quitté montréal
le mois dernier de retour au travail
dans le réseau de la santé
son conjoint et prend soin de leurs
enfants à la maison je pense qu'on parle
énormément du manque de ressources
humaines dans le réseau de la santé
actuellement mais on a comme un peu
vraiment les travailleurs pour leur
faciliter l'intégration travail
certaines listes d'attentes ont presque
doublé en un an
le cpe la barbouille à sainte adèle est
passé de 250 à 462 enfants sur sa liste
d'attentes le cpe la fourmilière à
mont-laurier 253 à 2 147 enfants
de leur côté les garderies en milieu
familial reçoivent plus d'appels qu'à
l'habitude
moi j'ai pas de classe disponible avant
septembre 2022 j'ai pu malgré tout
j'avais des appels de parents qui me
contactait au point où j'ai dû enlever
mon nom sur les listes d'attentes le
manque de relève accentue aussi le
problème de la profession est pas très
attractive
il n'y a pas tellement de personnes qui
ont envie de se lancer dans ce genre
d'étude hop il exerçait la profession en
octobre dernier québec a annoncé la
création de 226 nouvelle place de saint
sauveur jusqu'à mont tremblant
encore faudra-t-il trouver la main
d'oeuvre et attendre plus d'un an avant
de voir l'ouverture de nouvelles
garderies
c'est marc isabelle roche radio-canada
mort